[Music]
consumer prices are up
interest rates are rising
after about a generation global
inflation is surging again
why have millions of people around the
world become exposed to high inflation
and what can we do to bring it back
under control
henry
i'm going to start with you
what is inflation
inflation is
a rise in prices
uh it's a rise in average prices
measured by a basket of goods and
services typically it's when everything
gets expensive and when you think about
that it's important to realize it's not
when just one thing gets more expensive
that's what we call a change in relative
prices it's a change in overall prices
why do economists get so exercised about
it what happens if we just let inflation
kind of do its thing why do we care so
if inflation starts creeping up and i
think that that's going to last then i
might start pushing up you know the wage
increase that i would like or the um
prices that i would like to set and so
what you have what you end up having is
a situation where prices start creeping
up higher and higher and higher and we
know from places where inflation is
really high that that has a cost my own
view is that it's really more like an on
off switch either inflation is low
enough that people don't really have to
worry about it too much or it's high
enough that they pay a lot of attention
because they're feeling it every time
they buy anything and they have to
budget more carefully and all the things
that are going on right now and then it
really shoots up the scales in terms of
its political importance what are the
levers that policymakers have to make
inflation go up or down well there's
been a consensus for about three decades
or so that the primary responsibility
for controlling inflation is the
responsibility of the central bank
and that the way in which you control
inflation is by
raising interest rates when inflation's
too high which reduces the amount of
spending in the economy reduces the
amount of
money chasing a limited
pool of goods and services which is
ultimately what causes people to put
their prices up at the moment with
inflation too high the real question is
how high are central banks going to
raise interest rates in order to fight
it the next section we're going to is
what we're going to do about inflation
now um
obviously at the moment central banks
are raising rates pretty rapidly is this
going to cause inflation to come down
fairly quickly
as the central banks hope i mean that's
the question of the day really is how
effective central banks are going to be
in bringing down inflation the pace of
the monetary tightening is pretty steep
it's the steepest in america since the
early 1980s um so
after a period of hesitation
it looks like they're taking the problem
seriously
um the real question now is how much
pain that's going to cause i think
there's a sort of dirty little secret of
monetary economics and that's that the
actual mechanisms by which higher
interest rates flow through the economy
aren't that well understood it wouldn't
surprise me if they still have to go
significantly higher but i have complete
faith in the ability of higher interest
rates to bring down inflation
ultimately because if you raise rates
high enough it will it will as ratchet
said cause a cause a recession
eventually and that's very effective at
bringing inflation down if you're a
policy maker now like what else
are you or should you be thinking about
doing to get inflation expectations down
to the extent that inflation is about
the balance between demand and supply in
the economy you know other policies that
reduce aggregate demand would bring
inflation down as well and their you
know
tighter fiscal policy
raising taxes reducing spending would
bring down prices as well what we're
being reminded of right now is just how
unpopular inflation is how much people
dislike um you know prices pump going up
um the feeling that when they go to
supermarkets they can afford less and
less you know and and that
has political consequences and can drive
politicians and governments to try to do
things to rein in price rises the proof
is in the pudding central banks have to
deliver the low inflation and then
people will believe that inflation is
going to be low
thanks for watching to read the
economist coverage of inflation click on
the link and don't forget to subscribe